The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So folks,
we're going to get started
into thin films for a moment,
but I saw two of you, at least,
in the class at Eli Yablonovitch
talk on, gosh, what was it,
Tuesday?
Tuesday is was.
How many attended the
talk-- show of hands?
Three?
OK, three, awesome.
I must have missed one of
you-- very interesting talk.
This was a talk
about solar cells
given from the
perspective of somebody
who does light management.
And so I wanted to share with
you a book that is essentially
from where he takes his
efficiency calculations, which
are based largely
on thermal dynamics
and less on the
continuity equations--
Peter Wurfel's book
Physics of Solar Cells,
a brilliant, brilliant book.
I'm going to pass it around.
On page 33, very easy number
to remember-- 2 times 3, 3.
On page 33, he starts
delving into the derivation
that Eli Yablonovitch
presented during his talk,
so folks can follow along from
a thermodynamics point of view
and maybe read up a
little more and understand
that perspective.
But he very, very
briefly touched
upon essentially
the same physics
but from the perspective
of what we've
been talking about a
class in terms of carrier
densities and current flows.
He had it on the
bottom of a slide,
perhaps halfway
through the talk,
on four different bullet points.
Does anybody remember
what those were?
Why did he achieve such a
high efficiency conversion
efficiency with the
gallium arsenide cell?
Anybody remember that one?
He had a thin device, so by
thinning the device down,
if he's able to
concentrate the carriers,
in other words, if he's able
to collect all of the charge
carriers inside of
that very thin layer,
he'll have a higher
charge carrier density.
And the charge
carrier density is
what influences the
separation of the quasi Fermi
energies, which is what
influences the voltage output
of the device.
So he was able to
obtain a higher voltage
output because he had
a thinner solar cell.
He was able to concentrate the
carriers in that thinner region
by light trapping,
by light management.
And so as a result of having a
higher carrier concentration,
he had a higher separation
of the quasi Fermi levels
and hence a higher voltage
output of his device.
So in reality, it was very
simple from the perspective
of what we've been
learning in class here,
how he was able to obtain
the very high efficiencies
of gallium arsenide.
The physics is well known;
it's not new physics.
It's actually quite old physics,
and that that approach has
been used within the crystalline
silicon solar cell community
for some time as well.
The back surface reflectors
off of the devices
are highly optimized
and the texture,
as well, to scatter the light.
So I would invited
you to take a look,
and this is another
example of how
technologies can flow from
one photovoltaic system
into another.
So you can learn a lot
from material systems
that you aren't working
on necessarily yourself.
That's another take-home
message from the talk, at least
what I walked away with.
Any other impressions
that folks would
like to share before we
dive into the lecture?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just have question
about carrier collection.
How is it possible
to extract any energy
from carriers
which are generated
in front of the junction?
Because even if they
diffuse another junction,
they have nothing to fall down?
PROFESSOR: OK, so you have
to think about it always
from the perspective of
the minority carrier.
So if you generate an
electron-hole pair,
your minority carrier is now
a hole, in the n plus region.
And that hole diffuses
across the junction.
The electron stays.
AUDIENCE: I see, OK.
PROFESSOR: So did
anybody else pick up
on the point at the very
beginning of his presentation?
He said a P-N junction isn't
necessary to separate charge.
OK, that's fine.
We've talked about
heterojunctions.
We all agree there are other
ways to separate charge.
And he said an
electric field is not
necessary to separate
charge, but then
he immediately went into
discussing how the chemical
potential was slightly
lower in the contact
than it was in the
semiconductor, which
would result in a
charge imbalance, which
would result in a field.
And I think Gene Fitzgerald
from material science
and engineering department--
Professor Fitzgerald
called him out on it and
said, isn't there a field
there at the metal contact.
He said, quiet, wise guy,
we'll get back to you later.
But essentially his point was
a very small electric field
is necessary.
So his point was a
matter of degrees,
that you don't need a
massive electric field.
A very slight
field is all that's
necessary to start driving a
current through your system.
I just wanted to
make sure we didn't
leave that talk thoroughly
confused with our head
on backwards.
We're going to talk about
thin film materials today.
Why thin film solar cells?
Well, we've been talking about
crystalline silicon solar cells
that have a lower optical
absorption coefficient, so you
need a larger
amount of material,
or a larger optical
path length, to absorb
a significant
fraction of the light.
Already, in lecture
number two, we
saw how other
material systems that
have higher optical
absorption coefficients
are able to absorb this
equivalent amount of light
in a thinner amount of
material and less material.
So to put this in
perspective, what
we're talking about on one hand
with the crystalline silicon
devices is we might have
a device that's maybe
three or four times the
thickness of your hair
in crystalline silicon, and
for the other materials, so
these thin film
materials, you might
be talking about a material
absorber that has maybe
100th the thickness,
so something
under a micron or a 50th
of the width of your hair.
So that's the
perspective of scale
that we want to have in mind.
When we're talking
about thin films,
we're talking about thin
materials, really on the order
of one micron or so.
And even brittle materials,
at one micron thickness,
if deposited on compliant
substrates, can be flexible.
Another thing to keep in
mind in thin film technology
is that the scale of
the thin films industry
is about 1/10 that of
silicon industry right now.
So the crystalline
silicon industry
is going full force,
gangbusters right now,
and the thin film is
a growing fraction,
but it's on the order of 10%
of the total world market.
And many, many, many startup
companies, which are young,
dynamic, fun-- and that's why
today I'm not wearing a tie;
I'm in startup mode.
I'm a lot more relaxed.
We're going to be talking
about thin film technologies
and diving into some fun work.
So we'll talk about these
specific technologies
of thin film materials, and
before we get into those,
I'm going to address some
general topics about deposition
and, of course, general
parameters that affect
all thin film material systems.
We have to appreciate the sheer
diversity of technologies that
are out there on the market.
We have a variety of different
solar cell materials that
are available, some of
which are thin films,
other ones, wafer-based
crystalline silicon.
And all of these
technologies have
to consider cost resource
availability and, eventually,
environmental impact as well.
So these or some
of the things I'd
like you to keep on the
forefront of your mind as we
talk about these
different technologies.
Think about the broader picture,
and ultimately, this cost,
or the amount of money
per unit energy produced,
is really paramount in
determining marketability
and determining the
scales to which they'll
penetrate the market.
This is the one slide
that you have printed out.
You have one per pair of
students, or you should.
So if you don't have access
to that particular slide,
feel free to share it with
the person next to you.
This is representing
as a function of time,
going back to the 1970s, the
record solar cell conversion
efficiency.
The chart is maintained by
a certain Larry Kazmerski
at NREL.
Actually, he used to be the
head of NREL's solar program.
He stepped down a few years ago
after a very successful run--
many years.
And he's a bit of a father
of the US PV industry.
He's been around for
a long time and has
been tracking the growth
of the PV industry
and, of course, the improvement
of performance over time.
Many of these devices-- many
of these record efficiency
devices-- are very small
area, and many of them
were actually grown for the
intent, the explicit purpose,
of getting onto this chart.
And so when you're trying
to make a record efficiency
device, you do things
a little differently.
Let me give you
an example; you'll
optimize your anti-reflection
coding for air not for glass,
right?
So if you want to
minimize the reflectance
off the front surface,
you'll be optimizing it
for air, which has a
refractive index of one, as
opposed to glass, which has
a refractive index of 1.5.
So there are some tricks
that one does and engages in,
some are a little bit
under the table, too.
It has been done in
the past that people
would do an HF dip of their
silicon-based solar cells
right before measuring
the efficiency.
The hydrofluoric acid would
result in surface pacification,
but, of course, it would
result in a very low surface
adhesion of the metal, and so
the metal flake off afterwards.
It wouldn't pass the tensile,
but you would nevertheless
achieve instantaneously
higher efficiency.
Those practices have
largely been weeded out.
These were the
early days, when it
was a wild west of solar cells.
In more recent times, there
are some very strict standards,
and there are only a few
laboratories around the world
where you can take these
standard measurements.
The one at NREL
is extremely well
staffed in terms of the
quality of the people.
They're notoriously
under resourced,
but that's another issue.
But in terms of the quality
of the people there,
very, very good, very
thorough, very pedantic
and careful about taking
their measurements.
And if you ever have
a question about how
to perform a solar cell
efficiency measurement,
they're a very good resource.
Their website would be
an excellent place to go.
So these data points here versus
time represent the record cell
efficiencies.
They may be on very, very
small pieces of material.
They may be on a centimeter
squared, perhaps even smaller,
so they're not necessarily
representative of what is
in commercial production today.
Let me give you one example;
the record crystalline silicon
cells, which are in blue here,
has been around 25% for about
a decade-- actually,
a little more
than a decade-- and
the record efficiency
crystalline silicon device
has, in essence, not
been so planted for
many, many years.
There are a number
reasons for that.
It's very much approaching its
theoretical efficiency limit.
People haven't necessarily
tried specifically
to get a record efficiency
crystalline silicon device.
They're more intent on
making lower cost silicon
devices than record
efficiency ones,
and the average
module efficiencies
are somewhere down
at around here--
actually, somewhere
in the 13% to 15%
range for module, average
module efficiency.
You have some modules that
are in the 18%, 19% 20% range,
but most of them are
significantly lower.
And the record cell
efficiencies, as you can see,
is 25%.
So there's a significant
delta between what
is commercially available
and what the record cell
efficiency is.
There are several
reasons for this.
To make a record
efficiency cell,
you have to throw everything
at Liebig's law of the minimum.
You have to make sure that every
plank is really, really high.
That costs a lot
of money typically,
and so doing that cheaply
is a big challenge.
Some companies,
like First Solar,
for instance, has some
of the lowest cost
models in the market.
We'll describe how they're
made in a few slides.
First Solar forwent the
anti-reflective coating
on their glass for many
years, because it just
didn't make cost sense.
It didn't help optimize
this function right here.
Although, you'd get
more energy out,
the dollars that it took
to add that component just
didn't make sense for them.
So you have to think about a
few different perspectives.
You have to think
both in terms of cost,
and in terms of performance.
The performance, what it
does or what it tells you
is that this material
system has potential.
It has been demonstrated we
can get the high performance.
It's a proof of concept.
The trick now is to
get there at low cost,
and that's pretty much
what you should walk away
from this chart having seen.
Another thing to keep in mind
is that it takes a long time
to improve the performance
of a new material.
If you're starting out
somewhere down around here,
it's going to take you a while
to reach higher efficiencies.
Granted we can learn a lot from
the previous material systems.
We could learn a lot by
reading those old NREL project
reports that are available
online of all the people
who were working towards these
record efficiencies-- what they
did differently,
how they advanced,
and how they improved
cell performance--
and leverage that
information as you
try to develop your material.
But the fact of the matter is,
it'll still take a bit of time
to develop new technologies,
and you can see that
by some of the
newer materials that
are coming along down
here, for example,
the organic-based solar cells.
So thin films,
general issues-- so we
talked about the
advantages here,
that we're squeezing the
cost of the absorber layer
out of the module, which
is excellent from a cost
point of view.
But obviously, there
are trade-offs involved.
If it was all a
walk in the park,
we would be 100% thin films and
have abandoned silicon by now.
There are both advantages
in this advantages
with thin films.
Instead of disadvantages,
perhaps a happier way
of looking at this is
challenges and opportunities
for getting PhDs and
other advanced degrees.
So let's go up into advantages.
The advantages of thin
films, quite simply,
is that you're using a very thin
amount of material, so thin,
in fact, that it's virtually
insignificant in terms
of the total cost
structure of your module.
One perspective is that if
you're depositing a thin film
using a fairly
low-cost technique,
like a c spaced
sublimation type process,
you may be able to deposit
the material for as much cost
as it takes the
cardboard that separates
the modulus from each other in
the stack that's being loaded
onto the 18-wheeler
out of the factory,
to put things in perspective.
It's very cheap to
deposit these thin layers.
Now let's hop down to the
disadvantages real quick.
If you're depositing
a very thin layer,
and it's not high
efficiency, then you
need more glass, more
encapsulants, more framing
materials, more labor, and
everything for the same amount
of power out.
If your efficiency is low,
your costs will be higher.
Even if you have a dirt
cheap absorber layer,
you might as well get
the absorber for free.
If your efficiency is too
low, all the other commodity
materials are going to
outweigh that cost advantage
because the commodity
materials scale with area.
If you have low efficiency,
you need a larger area module
to make the same
amount of power.
So, at some point, if
you look at the cost
of the material
versus efficiency,
you start entering
negative territory.
You actually have to be paid.
If you're producing like
an 8% or a 7% module,
typically, you would have to
pay your customer for them
to accept your module.
So you really have to
achieve a minimum efficiency
target to be cost competitive,
and as a rule of thumb,
that's typically 10% to 12%
for today's cost of glass
encapsulance framing materials
and labor and installation
and so forth.
So back up to the
advantages-- there's
a potential here for a
very low thermal budget.
If we're able to print,
say, a micron-thick layer
onto a substrate,
remember, we go back
to that the high
speed printer analogy,
there's a potential for a
low thermal budget, which
means thermal budget
is the amount of heat
that you're introducing
during the processing.
As a result of a very
low thermal budget,
you have a potential
cost decrease.
Instead of heating things
up to 1,400 degrees
C over several hours, having
all that massive amounts
of electricity that
go into producing
the crystalline silicon
wafers, here, potentially, we
could be printing stuff
on flexible substrates.
So that's the thermal
budget argument.
In terms of conformal deposition
and flexible substrates,
there's a potential here
for roll-to-roll deposition.
Picture a newspaper plant,
where you have one roll of paper
on one side being pulled on
to another spool in the other,
with some deposition process
happening in between.
If you can deposit on a flexible
substrate, this is the vision.
And if you're not depositing
onto a flexible substrate
but onto hard substrate
like this one right here--
this is glass, a
thin film material
deposited on glass right
here, a very small one.
Oops, some tape on the front.
Let me get rid of that for you.
Here we go.
It's in a nice little
protective coating here,
so you can have a look at it
without worrying about getting
your fingerprints all over it.
And the company name is
fully removed-- check.
This is an example of a
thin film material deposited
on glass without any
anti-reflective coating, just
the absorber material,
so you can get a sense.
It looks great.
It's about a micron thick.
It's about 170 times
thinner than those wafers
that you saw on Tuesday.
So that's an example of
a thin film material.
It will be making its rounds.
There's a large amount
of technology transfer
with a thin film display, the
flat panel display industry,
with deposition on glass
like that one right there.
And there's a potential it'll
be very nice for building
integrated PV applications.
If you're able to
get rid of the glass
and deposit on a
conformal substrate,
you could envision roof shingles
or other flexible substrates
that would allow you conformal
coverage on undulating roof
tops and so forth.
Radiation hardness-- this
is just a small aside,
but there are some materials
that have better radiation
hardness than silicon.
What does radiation
hardness mean?
It means that if I send
something to outer space, where
we don't benefit
from the radiation
shield of our own atmosphere in
the Van Allen belts on earth,
and we have proton bombardment
and other forms of radiation
striking are module and creating
damage within the absorber
layer, some compounds are
naturally better at resisting
degradation of
performance than others,
and that's what
radiation hardness means.
So there are some
thin film materials
that are exceptional
for space applications.
The challenges and--
oh, go ahead, Ashley.
ASHLEY: Is gallium
arsenide one of them?
PROFESSOR: We're going to
show you in a few slides.
We'll compare them all as a
function of radiation exposure
time.
The disadvantages, or
shall we say challenges
and opportunities for PhD
and master's students,
lower efficiencies in
crystalline silicon potentially
larger module costs.
If you're able to improve the
performance of these thin film
materials, wow, you have
now equivalent performance
of crystalline silicon
but at much lower cost.
Good for you-- you have
a marketable product.
Potential for capital intensive
production equipment-- not all
of the production equipment
is as low cost and as low
thermal budget as simply
printing on a piece of paper.
As a matter of fact, that's one
of the more avant garde and R&D
type of deposition processes.
Most deposition processes
and the vast majority
of companies used are actually
quite capital intensive,
and the cost of the
equipment can add up.
Sometimes, not always,
but sometimes scarce
elements are used.
We're going to have a debate
about that on next class,
on Tuesday.
Put an asterisk next to that.
I'll get back to those as
soon as this slide is over.
And spatial uniformity is a
challenge during deposition.
Imagine trying to deposit a
film one-micron thick over glass
that is one meter in size.
You're talking about a six order
of magnitude aspect ratio here.
So we have to somehow deposit
a film a micron thick in layers
that are even
thinner, that might
be only a few tens or hundreds
of nanometers on top of that
and below that absorber
layer to separate charge,
for instance, and that's really
challenging to do on a very
large scale, and that
is an engineering
challenge or a process
engineering challenge that
had many startup companies
flailing for a long time.
Think of spatial homogeneity
in the following manner;
if you have one region
of your solar cell
that's producing a lot of
power, and the region next to it
is not, and they're connected in
parallel through the contacts,
power will flow from the good
region into the bad region.
So you have internal current
loops inside of your module.
That is essentially
decreasing the power output
of your module itself.
So that's why
homogeneity is important.
This is just to
represent the vision
of a roll-to-roll process in
the upper right-hand side there.
Kind of a visionary cartoon
that is being enacted
by one company, in
particular, Uni-Solar,
based out of Michigan.
They do have a
roll-to-roll process
and PCBD-- we'll
describe what that
is in a second-- deposition
of this material,
so-called amorphous silicon.
And here are some building
integrated solutions,
just showing you what
you can accomplish
or what the vision would be.
If had have this really flexible
substrate that you could
literally take it as a
roll from Home Depot,
bring up to your rooftop,
splay it out on your roof,
much like you'd lay down a
piece of tarp or plastic,
and take a staple gun or a nail
gun and drill it into location,
that would be an example of a
much reduced installation cost.
So you have the potential here
of reducing the installation
cost of solar as a result of
the form factor of your module.
And this here is another
example of a building
integrated photovoltaic
solution within films.
The fact that it looks
really nice, is really sleek,
you'd never guess that those
are solar panels there,
and that's, of course, from
an aesthetic point of view,
a huge benefit.
Common growth
methods-- how do we
make that sample of
copper indium gallium
diselenide, that thin
film material that happens
to be making its way around
the classroom right now,
how do we actually make it?
Well, not only the
material I just described,
there are other
materials as well.
We'll talk about the general
classes of growth method.
So this is the material science
processing class condensed
into a few slides.
Bear with me; this
very high level,
but it aims to highlight
the techniques that are
most commonly used in PV today.
We're going to
start with what are
called vacuum-based thin-film
deposition technologies.
And the reason I'm separating
vacuum from non-vacuum
is because if you
have a system that
is comprised of these large
stainless steel chambers
that you typically see when
you go walking in the physics
building, if you have
a vacuum chambers,
those are typically
quite costly,
at least the large
scale ones that
are in commercial production.
As the name would
suggest, you need
to have pumps to suck out the
air inside of the chamber,
and that's how you
create the vacuum.
The vacuum is necessary
because typically you're
transporting atoms from
some sort of source,
either gas or a solid
target, onto the substrate.
So you're transferring
individual atoms or clusters
of atoms from some
source onto the substrate
that will ultimately hold
your thin film device.
And that process
requires a limited number
of interactions of those
atoms or clusters of atoms,
in other words, a
large mean-free path,
as these make their
way to your substrate.
And that's why the vacuum
is typically required
in these deposition systems.
There are a variety of ways
to accomplish this goal.
One class of
techniques is called
Chemical Vapor Deposition,
often referred to as CVD.
This typically involves
flowing in some form of gas
into your chamber and
then allowing that gas
to react on the
surface of your sample
or above the surface
of your sample
and ultimately depositing
on the surface.
The chemistries involved in CVD
processes can be quite complex,
and the reaction
process itself can
be very difficult to master.
So you might have
some friends who
are involved in spectroscopy
shining lasers at their system
and looking at the
absorption lines
and trying to figure out how
these molecules are evolving
between when they're
inserted into the chamber
and when they actually
wind up as your film,
because understanding
the reaction,
the chemical reactions, that
take place is essential,
is key, to really
controlling the CVD process.
The other class of
technologies involved
is called PVD, or
Physical Vapor Deposition,
and this tends to be a
bit more straightforward.
We tend to have atoms
of a specific type.
They may be ionized, or
they may be charge neutral,
and they're making their
way to your substrate.
And the chemistry tends
to be much more simple,
but the apparatus around
it to give the incentive
for the atoms to
leave the target
and deposit on your substrate,
that tends to be more complex.
And so some of these
tools, especially
molecular-beam epitaxy can
be very expensive, very slow,
but very high quality, but
very expensive as a result.
And so a very
simple way to think
about the vacuum-based
deposition technologies
is a compromise-- this is an
oversimplification indeed,
but it's an easy
way to get started
about thinking of the parameter
space of all these techniques.
It's a compromise between
speed and quality.
Some of the techniques
that are fastest
also tend to be the
lowest quality materials,
and the other ones that
tend to be the slowest
tend to produce the
highest quality materials.
How do you optimize somewhere
in between, somewhere
in that parameter space, to
get reasonably high material,
just enough that you can produce
a high efficiency device--
remember that saturation
of device performance
versus diffusion length.
At some point, it just
doesn't make sense
to keep optimizing
your material.
You've got it good enough.
You're good to go.
So that's one of the things to
consider when you're choosing
your deposition system.
So let's go into a few
examples of these vacuum-based
deposition systems.
Within the PVD techniques,
within the Physical Vapor
Deposition techniques, one
of the most commonly used
in manufacturing, at
least in some startups--
you have examples like
MiaSole-- is sputtering.
And this sputtering
process is essentially
very, very straightforward.
You have a plasma.
The plasma consists of
atoms that are charged.
These are accelerated
toward your target, which
is comprised of the
elements that you want
to deposit onto your substrate.
Your substrate is
sitting up top.
And this target material is
sputtered off and eventually
makes its way up and sticks
to and eventually grows
the film on that orange
platen up here at the top.
That is your substrate.
The substrate is facing down.
Why is the substrate
looking down?
Why wouldn't you invert
this and put the target
on top and in the
substrate in the bottom?
What could happened
then in terms of purity
of the deposition process?
Let's go to Kristy.
AUDIENCE: Things
could fall onto it.
PROFESSOR: So stuff, gunk,
could fall onto your substrate.
You're trying to grow a
thin film a micron thick,
and you're trying to
avoid any imperfection,
and now gravity is working
against you in that case.
Because, if you
were to invert this,
your target would be on top.
You could have stuff raining
down onto your substrate.
There are a few people
who sputter down.
It's very tricky.
You have to be able to
control your process very well
and avoid flakes
from coming off.
There are folks who
sputter sideways,
saves some ground
space in their factory.
They might load things
vertically, put them in.
And many people, at
least in R&D, sputter up.
So again, you're
creating this plasma.
The charged species are
accelerated toward the target.
They sputter off
atoms, which are then
deposited on to your substrate,
which is there at the top.
And the film that was
just being passed around
is an example of
a sputtered film.
The spatial uniformity
of sputtering
over large area
depositions can be
in the order of a few percent.
So the ability to
control this process
in terms of spatial
uniformity is fairly good.
You could also employ
radio frequency modulations
to the bias voltage.
That's called RF sputtering
for Radio Frequency.
Industrial applications usually
involve large rotating targets.
So for those of
you-- how many people
actually work with some
sputtering materials
or have done it in the past?
One, two, three,
four, five, six, OK.
So you know that, at
least in the laboratory,
if you have a fixed target, you
wind up with that race track,
right?
So if you have a fixed
target in the lab,
and you're trying to
deposit your films,
if you wear it
down several hours,
eventually the metal that
you're trying to deposit,
or the ceramic that
will usually wind up having
a bit of shape to it.
Instead of being
flat on the surface,
you'll have what's
called a race track;
it'll dipped down
near the edges,
and that can result in a
change of the deposition
rate of the species that
you're trying to deposit.
And from a homogeneity
point of view,
that might be disastrous
in the company,
and so there are methods
to move your target
to avoid that sort of
effect from happening.
And when we talk
about large targets,
we're really talking about
large targets, right?
These aren't your lab scale
two-inch or three-inch,
these are much, much bigger
in commercial production.
So in terms of comparing
sputtering against other growth
technologies, there
are technologies
that are more conformal.
Because this is more of a
line-of-sight deposition
technique, the atoms are
moving toward your substrates.
But if you have some
shape to your substrate,
maybe you have a ledge
or a ridge, in that case,
you won't necessarily
coat that uniformly.
You might have less being
deposited on that edge rather
than the flat sections.
And so conformality of coverage,
or conformal surface coverage,
can be an issue with sputtering.
Let's talk about
the next technique
that is commonly used in
inorganic thin-film deposition.
Excuse me.
This is called metalorganic
chemical vapor deposition.
So again we notice the
CVD appearing at the end.
We know it's a Chemical
Vapor Deposition process.
MO in this case, standing
for Metalorganic.
The reason metalorganic
is because we typically
have a metal, like this
representing the indium right
here, and then little organic
compounds on the outside.
Those are methyl groups.
The little gray and the
two white dots, those
represent three methyl
groups around the indium, so
trimethylindium.
And what we do is we flow these
molecules into our reaction
chamber and control the
temperature gradients inside
in such a way to
have those molecules
deposit on the surface, leaving
the indium behind, or the metal
behind, and the
reaction products flow
away out the back, and that
is represented chemically
here on the surface.
This is zooming in right at
the surface of our sample
so right where the gas interacts
with the thin film material
that you're depositing.
This is representing the
incoming metalorganic molecule
reaching the surface.
This represents, right
here, the separation where
we have the indium shown
in black right here,
and then the methyl
groups are moving off,
and essentially, those
will be sucked out
of the chamber, leaving behind,
in this particular case,
you have a layer of indium
forming, probably another layer
of material underneath.
Say, for example, your
other species comprising
the thin film may be phosphorus,
so it would be indium phosphide
growth.
This metalorganic
chemical vapor deposition
is very nice from
the point of view
that you tend to form
homogeneous films-- very
good surface coverage.
The disadvantages would be that
many of the inputs and outputs
are toxix-- not always,
but many of them are.
They have to be
volatile and reactive
so that you can crack
the metal on your surface
and create the thin film.
If it wasn't reactive,
you would just
have it flowing through
and leaving, not having
a reactant with your substrate.
But because of the reactivity
involved, oftentimes
these are not very
friendly for human beings
or for other organisms.
It was not uncommon in the
early days of MOCVD reactor
development where they'd have
this little stack going up
to the roof, and then
when they'd do maintenance
on the roof, they'd find all
these dead birds lying around.
That obviously has improved
since people have put up
the appropriate filtration
on the output of their growth
system, so-called scrubbers, to
prevent toxic gases from being
released into the atmosphere.
But you do have
some old stories.
So the proper design of
metalorganic precursors
is essential.
You can easily see how if you
change the molecule that you're
bringing in, all of a sudden
now, your reaction temperatures
are changing.
The rate of deposition
is changing,
and you have to optimize your
growth process all over again.
So part of the trick
of doing good MOCVD
is knowing your chemistry, being
able to design or synthesize
these metalorganic precursors.
And the deposition process is
very sensitive to temperature,
pressure, the precise surface
orientation, and preparation,
what carrier gases, as well, are
mixed in with the metalorganic
precursor that
you're putting in,
and the byproducts obviously
need to be managed.
So that's MOCVD in a nutshell.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And pure quality
is much better with MOCVD
than it is for
sputtering, right?
PROFESSOR: It depends
on a lot of factors.
So the reason the
purity of MOCVD
is generally better
than sputtering
is because the mass
flow controllers
necessary to control
the gas flow specific
for particular types of gases.
Now, in sputtering,
because of the versatility
of the sputtering chamber,
you could take this target out
and put-- maybe
Ashley comes along
into your sputtering
chamber, and she
puts in another target
of another metal.
And now you're depositing
two different metals
in the same sputtering chamber.
You're going to get
cross contamination.
There are things you can do to
minimize cross contamination.
You can have a chimney around
your target to prevent flakes
from coming down.
You could sandblast
the sidewall coating
and so forth to prevent
stuff, gunk, from building up
around the side,
but you're still
going to get a lot of
cross contamination here.
And furthermore, the
purity of your film
is dictated by the
purity of your re-target.
And if you go online and look
at [INAUDIBLE] or CERAC or some
of the big metal selling
firms, which are essentially
from where the target
manufacturers are purchasing
their precursors and
they compact them
and make their targets, the
target purity, or the metal
purity, is only on the order
of maybe 2/9 to 6/9 pure,
typically within that range.
So from an MOCVD
point of view, you
could do a distillation
process and increase
the purity of your precursor
gas and avoid that.
So I think two big reasons why
MOCVD can produce higher purity
films in the
sputtered system, one
is the quality of the
target, and the other,
I think, bigger parameter, at
least in our growth system,
is cross contamination.
And whenever you
deposit, say, an EML--
they have a sputtering system
there from AJA, or over
at Harvard CNS, there's another
AJA sputtering system there--
you're going to get
cross contamination.
Just look to the log
book and see what
people have tried to deposit.
It gets kind of scary.
PECVD, Plasma Enhanced
Chemical Vapor Deposition--
so similar to the previous
variety right here,
but instead of saying,
OK, we're going
to put the burden of the
design, the scientific design,
onto this interface right here
and on to the chemist, who
has to design this molecule
that reaches a surface
and breaks up in just the right
way in an orderly fashion,
leaving behind the metal and
letting the other gases go
away, what we're
going to do here
instead is to shift the burden
of separation onto the plasma.
So the centers around
the physicists.
We can flow in gases.
We can break them up
inside of a plasma,
atomize them or, at least,
create radicalized versions
of them and then
allow them to it
on to the substrate--
very simple in theory.
In practice, what happens
inside that plasma,
depending on the
temperature, depending
on the frequency
and other factors,
you'll get different types--
and the pressure, especially
the pressure-- you'll get
different types of molecules
forming in the plasma.
They may be charged, and
they'll be accelerated
toward your substrate
and eventually
grow and form a thin film.
But depending on what
species you have up there
that is being deposited
on your surface,
you'll get different
types of thin films
growing-- different
quality material.
And so, again, this
shifts the burden back
to the spectroscopist to
measure what is exactly
the composition of that plasma.
What is the active molecule
that's being accelerated
and deposited on the surface?
And usually it's some
probability distribution
function of varied species.
The plasma is created
by this radio frequency.
Let's put it this
way; usually you
have a plasma frequency
of around 13.56 megahertz.
Does anybody know why
this 13.56 keeps on coming
up over and over again?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] energy
to the ionized hydrogen, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, if
we're thinking about eV,
that would certainly be the
energy necessary to remove
the electron from
the hydrogen atom,
but this is another reason.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's a
special bend that's
dedicated for these crazy
noise-emitting medical and
industrial purposes.
PROFESSOR: Exactly,
so this is falling
within the radio
frequency regime, which
would affect communications.
And if everybody was allowed
to run rough shod around,
creating these very
high intensity emission
sources of radio
frequency waves,
we would very likely have
interruptions to our police
communications or maybe even
our radios or cell phones.
And so, at some point,
they had to say, look,
we have to assign definite
bands within the radio frequency
space and allocate them
to specific purposes.
In one band, they allocated
to all the scientists
and medical personnel
and said, you
have to operate your equipment
in these specific bands,
and we'll give
you a few of them,
because we know that one
frequency doesn't work for all
the things you're trying to do.
But for medical equipment,
for scientific equipment,
and I believe even some home
electronics, like microwaves,
there are specific
bands dedicated to them.
And that's why we have
this 13.56 number popping
up over and over again.
The reality is that if
you change the frequency,
you'll change the
nature of your plasma.
You may change the deposition
rates and the quality
of your film as well.
And so there are people
who get special permits
and have these radio
frequency shielded
rooms, where they do experiments
outside-- or excursions
outside-- of the
13.56 megahertz range.
So this is PCBD-- excellent
conformal surface coverage
again.
Because you're biasing
your substrate,
you're able to conform.
The electric field
is usually always
perpendicular to the
surface, and so the angle
of entry of those atoms or
molecules, the ionized species,
entering the surface is going
to be normal to that surface.
And you can get good coverage
around rough textured surfaces.
The deposition is very sensitive
to temperature, pressure,
power, carrier gases.
Power of the-- here,
as well, shown.
And the byproducts,
as well, need
to be managed because
sometimes you're sucking out--
in this particular case, you
could be pulling out silane,
as shown right there,
and we talked about all
of the risks involved a
silane in our last class.
So, as you could guess, each
of those different deposition
techniques is used or is favored
for specific material systems.
And we shouldn't
forget, as we talk
about all these fancy
vacuum equipment that
look nice and cool as you
walk through the labs,
and you see these big
stainless steel chambers,
we shouldn't forget about the
simpler, lower cost, lower
thermal budget, lower
capital equipment cost
techniques-- the solution-based
deposition methods.
And these involve printing.
They involve a
electrodeposition,
spin casting,
colloidal synthesis,
layer-by-layer deposition--
developed here at MIT--
and other technologies as well.
I want to point out
two technologies,
in general, the first of which
is still under some development
printing.
Obviously, we have
inkjet printers.
That's pretty straightforward.
But printing
fractional solar cells
is something being
commercialized
by only a handful of companies,
Nanosolar being one of them.
And I would say there aren't
any authoritative textbooks that
will describe for
you their technology,
because it's
largely under wraps.
They're a startup company, and
it's not publicly available.
Electrodeposition, on the other
hand, is fairly well known.
You're, again, applying
a voltage difference
between two electrodes, one of
which will be your substrate,
and depositing a
species contained
within your electrolytic
solution onto that substrate,
growing your layers.
Because you're growing
it at room temperature,
these films, I would say,
tend to have rough surfaces.
That could be a downside
of electrodeposition.
They might have some
pinholes as well.
But you do get fairly
large grained materials.
It can be a very gentle growth
process, and, of course,
the advantage is
lower temperature.
So you have a variety of
different growth techniques.
Let's talk about the general
issues involved with thin films
in general, and then we'll dive
into the specific materials.
So taking the same tact as
we've taken the full class,
going from fundamentals
toward the technologies.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious; do you
know of any companies that
actually use electrodeposition?
PROFESSOR: I know
of some companies.
Let me think which I
can talk publicly about.
So IBM, they presented at the
Electrochemical Society meeting
last Monday here in Boston.
They're an example
of a company that
is developing
electrochemical deposition
processes for material systems,
including copper zinc tin
sulfide and copper indium
gallium diselenide.
We'll talk about the
latter in a few slides,
but that's one
example of a company.
So general issues in thin
films-- thin film compounds
are typically, not
always, but typically,
binary, ternary, quaternary,
or multinary semiconductors.
Meaning you don't have
just one element comprising
the semiconductor species.
You might have several, and
they form a crystal structure
with repeating structure but
alternating atoms typically.
And so, if you have multiple
atoms in one compound,
a couple of issues
could arise and need
to be controlled
to grow good films.
The first involves
phase stability.
What is shown right here in
mulitnary parameter space,
this is the chemical
potential zinc, copper,
and tin in a so-called zinc
copper tin sulfide material
system.
This red fin right here is
showing you the parameter space
within which this
compound is stable.
If your stoichiometry takes an
excursion from that red fin,
you could wind up in
a bi-phase regime.
Meaning you have CZTS
and something else,
a copper tin sulphide,
a zinc sulfide,
or some other
species that happens
to be nearby in phase space.
One way to think
about this is it's
just you have a
homogeneous material.
If you exceed a solubility limit
in one direction or another,
you'll have precipitation
of a secondary phase.
So you have to make sure
that in a gross perspective,
on a percents basis,
you're in the right regime
of stoichiometry.
Stoichiometry being the
ratio of different elements
in your system.
So it's like cooking; you need
the right set of ingredients
to make the right material.
Now, that has to do with-- large
excursions from stoichiometry
can result in phase
decomposition.
Small excursions from
stoichiometry, a much more
subtle effect can occur.
Let's imagine for a moment that
we have two species comprising
are binary material.
One species has three
valence electrons.
The other species has
five valence electrons.
Now, because of a small
error in stoichiometry,
maybe something in the
order of a few tens
or hundreds of parts per
million in stoichiometry,
we didn't get the
ratio just right.
We were off by a little bit.
Now we have one of our
compounds in excess
and the other one in deficiency.
If we have a different number
of electrons surrounding
the atoms, we could wind up with
an excess free carrier density.
In other words, you could
self-dope your material
if you're unlucky,
in other words,
if the material system
has a propensity for this.
And you can change the
free carrier concentration,
and because the free carrier
concentration is changing,
you might even
change your mobility.
So there are some
effects that can
occur as a result of small
excursions from stoichiometry.
As a result of the
self-doping, you're
shifting the Fermi energy
inside your semiconductor.
And as a result of
shifting the Fermi energy,
it might lead to a
cascade series of events.
There could be
other defects that
form as a result of the
Fermi energy change.
You could have other
so-called antisite defects.
Atoms could switch positions
inside of your lattice,
and as a result of that,
have very low minority
carrier lifetime in
certain materials.
So nailing the stoichiometry
both from a very large sense,
to avoid phase
decomposition, instead
of having a dalmatian
film, you have phase
pure film, and from
a local perspective,
once you get on to
this phase space
where you can grow
your film well,
you want to make sure that your
stoichiometry is controlled
to avoid self-doping
and to prevent
certain types of
intrinsic point defects
from forming that might
lower minority carrier
lifetime or change
carrier concentration,
change other properties
of your film.
For those who are working
on these sorts of materials,
I'm happy to talk ad
nauseam about these topics,
maybe after class, since this
is a more detailed subject.
Another topic of interest
in thin films is grain size.
At some point, grains
don't matter anymore.
The grain size,
typically if you exceed
the thickness of your film
by about a factor five.
In other words, the
grain diameter's
about five times wider than
the thickness of your film,
grain size is not
as much of an issue.
But if you do have
very small grains,
they can impact performance,
because carriers will interact
with those grain boundaries.
And depending how
recombination active they are
or where the grain boundary
is pinning the Fermi energy,
the density of state at
that, at the grain boundary,
will dictate the effect
on device performance.
So these are some
very rough plots
in crystalline silicon
for thin film devices
and for some thicker
ones as well.
So performance is a
function the grain size.
And I show crystalline silicon
because the data is really
well developed for it,
but you see similar types
of plots for organic materials,
for some inorganic thin film
materials, like
CIGS and so forth.
And this convolutes a
few different parameters.
You have to take into account
that the recombination
activity of the grain
boundary is also a factor.
The next topic, general
topic of interest,
another tool that we'll want
to have an our material science
toolkit as we start
designing these materials,
we have to think
about the interfaces
between the different materials.
Especially in thin
films, interfaces
are so important because
we don't much bulk anymore.
So the device could
really be affected
or device performance
really reduced
if we don't pay proper
attention to our interfaces.
What are these plots over here?
These plots are used to grow
some very high efficiency
materials, for example, by
MOCVD or molecular-beam epitaxy.
And what is represented
on the horizontal axis
is lattice constant.
Lattice constant refers to the
equilibrium spacing of atoms
inside of your material.
So this regular repeating unit
cell that defines a crystal
has a certain lattice
constant, a certain distance--
physical distance--
shown here in angstroms.
The energy of the gap is
shown on the vertical axis.
And if we want to select two
or three of these materials
to stack on top of one
another to absorb well
at different portions
of the solar spectrum,
we'll be choosing, for example,
one band gap at around 1.9 eV,
another band gap
of 1 eV, or maybe
if we want three
materials, we'll
go even higher at the top
end and lower at the low end.
So we'll stack
different materials
on top of each other to
absorb preferentially
in different regions
of the solar spectrum
and hence exceed the
Shockley-Queisser efficiency
limit, because now we're
absorbing well in two or three
different colors as
opposed to just one.
And the energy gap
here is important
because you want
maybe one material
at 1 eV, one material
at about 1.9 eV.
But you also want to
make sure that they
can grow on top of each
other, that you're not
going to get a mismatch
of that interface,
that the lattice constants
aren't so different that you
wind up with these dangling
bonds at the interface, where
you have an atom
coming down and nothing
on the other side
for it to bond to.
And so you need to make sure
that the materials that you
grow are matched in lattice
constant but varying
in band gap, if you're trying
to grow a multi-junction device,
if you're trying to grow
a very high efficiency
solar cell device.
And so the growth or matching of
materials one on top of another
is important, especially
for the multi-junctions,
also for some of the
single junction materials
if you really want to minimize
the interface recombination.
So let's look at
this growth system
up here, the one
that is typically
used in high efficiency
solar cell materials.
We have germanium right here,
gallium arsenide, and indium
gallium phosphide,
which is essentially
a mixture between
gallium phosphide up here
and indium phosphide down here.
You can alloy the two together
and get an indium gallium
phosphide mixture and stack
these three materials on top
of one another-- germanium,
gallium, arsenide,
and indium gallium phosphide.
They have three
different band gaps.
The absorb in three different
regions of the solar spectrum.
But they have a very
similar lattice constant,
and so the interfaces will
be very well maintained.
That's an example of using
a chart like this to design
your solar cell materials.
Next topic is
material abundances.
If we're trying to engineer
all of these other parameters
that we've been talking about--
the lattice constant, the band
gap, the grain size
that also is a function
of how the material grows,
the ability to self-dope.
We have all of these material
issues that we have first
and foremost in our minds.
We go to the periodic table.
We find some
compounds that work.
We're really happy about it.
But then, all of a sudden,
life comes along and slaps us
the face and says,
well, we don't
have enough of this
material to really scale
to get all the way to the
terawatt cell [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, I wish I had known about
this before when I first
got started.
So we're presenting to you
upfront the state-of-the-art
of what is known about
material abundances.
And these last two studies
right here, APS Energy Critical
Elements and the DOE Critical
Material Strategy, both of them
represent a synthesis of
the information, essentially
the equivalent to the
IPCC reports in climate
change, but the best
synthesis that we
have right now
about the abundances
of different elements out there.
There are as well a
variety of different papers
that have been published in the
subject over the last couple
of decades or even earlier.
So what we have to keep in mind
is that our stardust out there
is not in infinite supply.
Every element we have on
the planet that we know of
came from fusion
reactions in stars,
and there was a probability
distribution function
of the appearance of those
elements as a function of z
on the planet as a result biased
toward the lighter elements.
And some of the
heavier elements are
in lesser supply, that we
know of, on the Earth's crust.
Not to say that the
deposits don't exist.
Not to say that these
studies right here
are the authoritative
end-all and be-all.
We might discover next
year or next month
for tomorrow huge deposit
of a particular element
at a specific spot, let's
say, under the Arctic.
But from what we know right
now, that's the stardust
that we have to work with.
These are our abundances.
So if you'd like to
design around it,
I'd advise looking into
those reports as well.
And finally, radiation
hardness, getting back
to Ashley's question, gee,
what are the most radiation
hard species?
This is the efficiency of solar
cell performance normalized
at the very start
of a test, and this
is the equivalent
radiation damage.
You could also think about
this as the amount of momentum
or energy depending
transferred to the atoms
inside of your
semiconductor that
would result in lattice
damage that would result
in a decrease of minority
carrier lifetime or mobility,
which ultimately would
impact cell performance
and efficiency.
We can see that
different material
systems have different
degrees of radiation hardness.
Some maintain their
high efficiency
until very high radiation
dose, and others
degrade much quicker.
And look at this.
This is a dose in orbit per
year, right around there.
And you can already begin
to see that some of our most
common compounds are not doing
too well out there-- not doing
too well in outer space.
So we have the
radiation hardness
to take into account if we're
putting these solar panels
out there into outer space.
This is one older study
I would definitely
encourage you to look.
There may be some newer studies.
As the solar cell
efficiency improves,
they become more
sensitive because you
begin decreasing your
efficiency with smaller
variations in the minority
carrier diffusion length.
So those charts make look a
different as time goes by.
AUDIENCE: Is the effect of
the radiation cumulative?
So for example, gallium
arsenide or any of these
would just continue to degrade
as they're out in space?
PROFESSOR: So is effective
radiation dose cumulative?
I am not the expert on
this particular topic.
But from what I know about
radiation exposure of detectors
at synchrotrons, which
is a little similar,
not quite the same, the
mechanisms involved with this
essentially involve
atomic displacements
within the lattice.
You have atoms physically
being displaced
from their equilibrium
positions as they interact
with this incoming radiation.
And the probability that it
occurs is a function of time,
will increase per unit
volume, and hence it
can be thought of as
accumulative exposure effect.
The first order impact would be
on minority carrier diffusion
length, impacting both
lifetime and mobility.
And to the effect that you have
a relationship between exposure
time-lattice displacement,
lattice displacement-minority
carrier diffusion length,
minority carrier diffusion
length and efficiency, you might
be able to model this effect.
That would be my
uninformed answer.
Again, you might want to
look this up yourself.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Do you know why the
cadmium telluride improves?
PROFESSOR: Oh, why does it
improve with efficiency?
I don't know
specifically about why
that is for this
particular case,
but do know that some
materials are what
are called defect tolerant.
Some are more naturally able
to withstand antisite defects
or a certain concentration
of damage, internal surfaces,
voids, grain boundaries.
Cad-tel, cadmium telluride,
is fairly defect tolerant.
It's one of nature's gifts
to humanity in that regard.
The degree to which a material
can be defect tolerant
depends partly on
the carrier density.
If you have very
high carrier density,
you tend to screen defects.
Another reason why they could
be defect tolerant-- all
of these compounds are
somewhere between an ionic
and a covalent semiconductor.
In a covalent semiconductor,
those materials
tend to be very defect
intolerant because there's
the conduction band and valence
band as a function of position,
tend to be very flat.
The material tends to be
fairly homogeneous throughout
the electron densities,
fairly well distributed
in a covalently bonded material.
In an ionic material, you tend
to have charge localization.
So energy as a
function of position
might look like this
on an atomic scale
as you go from one atom to
the next atom on your lattice,
to the next one, to the
next one, to the next one,
and that reflects the
localization of charge
in your material.
Those materials can be
more defect intolerant,
because conduction can happen
more from a hopping mechanism
than from a band
conduction mechanism,
and this is really
a gradient between,
and most materials, they tend
to be partially ionic partially
covalent going
down the list here.
And there's a bit of a shift
between cadmium sulfide
in zinc sulfide in terms
of the ionicity covalence.
So cad-tel would be
with the chalcogen
two lower than sulfur
on the periodic table.
I would imagine it would be
at this transition as well,
but I'd have to look that up.
Gives a place to get started
and read more about it.
And then reliability
and degradation--
this is important.
This is a crystalline
silicon module
being loaded into
environmental testing chamber.
Inside of that
chamber, the module
is going to be put
through hell and back.
The temperature is
going to be raised.
The humidity is going
to be pumped in.
Sometimes ultraviolet
light is even
put in there in some of the
more modern advanced ones.
And then the temperature
can drop down
to temperatures as low
as minus 40 degrees C,
depending on what the
environmental chamber is
designed to do, exactly
how it's designed
to stress or test your module.
And the idea is to promote
an accelerated degradation
of the module on purpose to test
what its failure modes will be,
and we'll see these we go
take a tour of Fraunhofer
CSE in a couple weeks.
This is a crystalline silicon
module being loaded in.
If you were to put a
thin film material--
and crystalline silicon are
materials very, very thick,
and we said at the native
oxide was very tenacious.
It was only a few tens or maybe
hundreds of angstroms thick,
and the junction depth was
about on the order of a micron.
If you have water attacking
the surface of you
silicon wafer, water
vapor, really not too
much of an issue, and silicon's
is fairly inert anyway.
But now if you take a fairly
reactive material, a thin film
material that might react with
air or might react with water,
and it's so thin that the these
rusting modes, or reaction
modes, the weathering
modes, can really
impact a large fraction of
the thickness of your device.
Now you've become a
lot more sensitive
to accelerated degradation.
Now you've become a lot more
sensitive to the elements,
and this includes
both oxygen and water.
So if the ambient
is able to penetrate
through the encapsulate and
get to the active absorber
material, you may have
accelerated degradation
of module performance
as a result.
And so there also
some unique failure
modes within thin film modules.
If you have two different
species comprising
your compound, one
of them might be
prone to move in electric field.
For example, copper is
notorious for zipping along
in electric field,
in electromigrating.
And so that's a
failure mode that
doesn't exist in large thick
crystalline silicon modules
but could existent
in thin films.
And so because of all of this,
and because of the growing
realization that the way we
test crystalline silicon modules
and drive them failure
is not the same
that we might be able to achieve
failure in a thin film module.
There are newer
testing protocols,
such as this IEC 61853,
that have been introduced
in an attempt to do test
appropriately thin film
modules for their
respective failure modes.
And this is, I would say,
still work in progress.
So much so, that we
have a group project
focused in part on this.
It's still a work
in process to try
to figure out how
do we appropriately
test these thin film
modules toward the point
where they can fail.
Any questions so
far on these topics?
Because these are general issues
that will affect all thin film
materials, I wanted
to make sure that we
were comfortable with
these general topics
before we dove in any
detail into the technologies
themselves?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A question
about lattice matching--
is it important to lattice
match the semiconductor
to the contact as well?
Or is that not as important
PROFESSOR: So the
question was is it
important to lattice match the
semiconductor to the contact?
So let me emphasize that in
many semiconductor contact
combinations you would have
a highly doped semiconductor
right before the contact, a
very localized region of highly
doped semiconductor that would
create a tunneling injunction.
In that case, the density
of states at the interface
doesn't matter because you
have a tunneling junction.
You're be able to tunnel
straight from the semiconductor
into the contact.
The lattice matching
would matter, though,
if you didn't have a
tunneling junction.
If you had a regular
Schottky ohmic contact,
then you might have to
worry about the density
of interface states,
which would be regulated
by the number of dangling
bonds, and then you
might want every
single atom pairing up
with a neighbor
on the other side.
So lattice matching would be
important for the contacts
there.
All right, fun
stuff-- wow, we've
had a good dose of material
science of the day.
Thin film cost
structure-- I just wanted
to highlight one quick thing.
This material right here, that's
not the absorber material.
The absorber material is
a really tiny fraction
of the material.
This comprises the other
materials within the module
as well.
So the encapsulates,
the glass, and so fort,
just keep that in mind
as a kind of asterisks.
So it's typical thin
film cost structure.
It evolves with time.
This is a few years
old, this slide,
but it gives you a
sense, a feeling.
In terms of global production,
this is a year-old data now
from 2010.
During this past year-- so this
was 2009 data shown in 2010.
The 2010 market was very harsh
for the thin film producers,
many of which tend to be in the
United States and in Europe.
In 2010, prices
dropped quite a bit,
and that favored the
low-cost Chinese solar cell
manufacturers,
many of which were
invested in crystalline
silicon technology.
So by no detriment
to the technology
itself, market
dynamics worldwide,
due to other factors, tended
to favor crystalline silicon
in the past year.
And the market
share of thin films
contracted a bit so it's now
about 90% crystalline silicon,
10% then films
worldwide in 2010.
But the break down between
the different thin film
technologies, we had the
so-called cadmium telluride,
CIGS, so that's Copper
Indium Gallium Diselenide,
and amorphous silicon.
And the dynamic
between 2009-2010
was that the amorphous
silicon shrank a bit.
CIGS grew, and cad-tel continued
growing, but more marginally
because it was already
big to begin with.
So you could think of
this red portion growing
at the expense of the green,
if you want to translate this
into 2010 numbers.
So what is CIGS, cad-tel,
amorphous silicon--
what are those materials?
Well, we'll get into that.
I think the best thing to do is
to leave this for next class.
I'll briefly go
over cad-tel just
because it is so important.
It is the biggest-- the
single biggest US solar cell
manufacturer is producing
cadmium telluride solar cells,
or cad-tel for short.
And to make just a description
of what you're solar panel
would look like
in cross section,
this is your glass
on the backside here.
This ITO Indium Tin Oxide.
It is a what?
A transparent conducting
oxide, very good.
So the ITO is a transparent
connecting oxide.
Your light, your sunlight,
is coming in through here.
So this is electrically
conductive layer,
but it's transparent, so it's
allowing the sunlight through.
Tin oxide, we'll get
to that in a second.
Cadmium sulfide and
cadmium telluride--
so the cadmium
telluride layer is
a layer that's absorbing
most of the sunlight
and producing
electron hole pairs.
The cadmium sulfide is
providing the header junction
separating charge at the header
junction between the cad-tel
and the cad-sulfide.
This tin oxide is generally
an intrinsic layer.
It's assisting here with the
ITO on the front contact,
and then you have your back
contact that extracts charge
from the back.
There are a couple
more tricks to creating
a good cad-tel device that
involve chlorine treatment
and passivation of defects.
That's where some of
the activation comes in.
This is another view
of the cad-tel device
in cross section,
another example.
This transparent conducting
oxide, in this case,
is fluorine doped tin
oxide, another TCO material.
But very similar structure
here, the cad-tel
being the p-type
material, and cad-sulfide
the n-type material.
The thicknesses of these
different layers you can see.
The cad-tel is only
a few microns thick,
and the cad-sulfide
this is even thinner.
It's a very thin layer just
serving to separate the charge.
The band diagram of a cad-tel
solar cell is shown right here.
We have the cad-tel here and
the cad-sulphide right here.
So you can see the junction.
Notice, because of the
thickness of this layer,
the band bending
at these interfaces
extends quite an
appreciable percentage
of the total thickness
of your device.
Whereas in crystalline
silicon, we
have the band bending right near
the junction region, so right
within a few hundreds of
nanometers, maybe a micron away
from the junction, and the
device is 100 microns thick.
So we had 100 microns
approximately of this flat band
condition, at least in the dark.
Here we have bending extending
an appreciable percentage
of the total thickness
of our device,
just by virtue of the fact
that we have such a thin film.
And the characteristics,
the deposition technology
of cad-tel, as I said, it's
nature's gift to humankind.
If you put cadmium and
tellurium in together
in a pot and start heating it
up, what evaporates is cad-tel.
It congruently evaporates.
So you could use a process
called close space sublimation,
where you essentially
sublime your cad-tel,
and you deposit it
onto your substrate.
If you try to do this
with most other compounds
in the periodic
table, you'll get
either one element or the other
element evaporating first.
They'll create an overpressure.
They'll evaporate
off, and you won't
get your compound
depositing, but you'll
get one element depositing on
your substrate preferentially.
cad-tel, again, nature's
gift to humankind.
The two come off together and
form a cad-tel layer and so
that congruent evaporation makes
it very nice from a deposition
point of view-- very low cost,
high throughput deposition
process for solar benefits from.
Environmental
concerns-- cadmium has
raised quite a bunch of
concerns amongst folks
in environmental groups because
it's a known carcinogen.
It is responsible
in Japan for, I
believe it was called
the itai-itai ban, which
means "the ouch-ouch disease."
It was a disease
that was acquired
by folks exposed to cadmium
during manufacturing.
And as a result,
cad-tel solar panels
are not allowed to be
installed in Japan.
So First Solar cannot sell
its cad-tel products in Japan.
There are very tightly
regulated emissions laws
in the EU and the United States,
especially in the EU, where
cradle-to-grave recycling
of cad-tel solar panels
are necessary.
So you'll see a lot of
cad-tel solar panels
in large field installations or
in commercial buildings where
it's very easy to collect
them all after their 20-
or 25-year life span and bring
them back to the factory,
as opposed to having
them distributed
amongst hundreds of
thousands of smaller systems
deposited on rooftops.
The arguments in favor of having
cadmium inside of solar panels
is the following.
It's better to tie
up cadmium inside
of a relatively inert compound,
cad-tel, then to have it go off
and cause problems on its own.
If you heat it up, the cad-tel
would evaporate congruently.
Typically cadmium is
so-called "negligible" amounts
are released during fires, and
they put it in between quotes
because these are studies,
very good studies,
and I trust the work coming
out of the [INAUDIBLE] group
very much.
His critics would argue
that, well, the studies
were paid for, in
part, by First Solar,
so how do you trust
studies like that?
I would counter and say,
this is a pretty good group.
Out of all the people
to life cycle analysis,
he's within the top tier.
So it's some
question as to that.
People do question were
the temperatures used
in these studies representative
of what you would actually
get in the hot zone of
a fire and so forth.
There's a public fear
and perception issue.
It's a big deal.
And the folks would argue that
much less cadmium is released
per kilowatt hour than,
say, in a battery, where
we would use a nickel cadmium
battery, for instance.
And safe production methods
now-- fully automated,
and recycling is
guaranteed by law.
So have arguments in
favor and against.
I'm going to stop
right here, and I'm
going to pull aside the
teams during the last 15
minutes of class.
I emailed to you.
If those of you had checked
your email before last night
at 5 o'clock, should have
received an email saying you're
on a particular project team.
Find your partners,
cluster together.
Joe and I are going
to come around
to spend a few minutes
with each of you
just to make sure that
our first steps are clear
and that we have a forward
path and we gain some momentum.
So self-assemble and don't
leave the room before the chance
to come talk to you.